who just put 100 of these in their
at you you're body pretty unhealthy
today you might need one of these
nutrients by sweetums if you can't beat
them sweethearts
i love that song oh i need to go check
my email
we're gonna sell these in the park now
they're healthy
holy god no they're not they're terrible
for you no they're not there's a picture
of lance armstrong on there yeah look at
the ingredients high fructose corn syrup
corn syrup she's only eight grams of fat
yeah per serving a bar is four servings
well people seem to enjoy them look how
happy everybody is
[Music]
yeah that's uh a sugar rush yeah yeah
that makes sense
they're gonna crash soon and it's not
gonna be pretty yeah i'm gonna crash
them too cause i've eaten like 40 of
these
oh god generally i like to stay out of
other people's business
but pawnee is the fourth most obese city
in america
the kids here are beefy they're just
husky
big bone plus-sized chunk monsters
i call them like i see them
leslie yeah let's get some almonds in
you okay
okay get it you can't open them
oh back to work and seal the edges by
crimping with a fork ah crap
ben what's up chris come on in man i
already did
so uh how you been how you doing how are
you great actually i'm just
learning how to make a color zones uh
or as you americans like to say calzones
do you want one no i find calzone fatty
and unnecessary so you've hit a bit of a
rough patch
and i care about you so i just want to
make sure that you're doing okay
chris honestly i'm great okay
oh my god a 98 match it's a soulmate
level match i i've never seen anything
this high before
awesome okay i know what you're thinking
and
you know what you have to forget about
ben he had his chance and he blew it
this computer could have found the
future mr leslie knope
yeah okay entire universe of guys i
might date let's see what you got
this is craig at hoosiermate.com how can
i help you craig your service is crap
can you be more specific yes your
soulmate match was totally wrong for me
i mean i like him as a friend and
everything but i never go out with him
he's like a little sister to me
we have a very sophisticated algorithm
that's paired up thousands of couples i
actually
met my wife on the site really well
that's not gonna last excuse me you
heard me your marriage is a sham goodbye
chris
i can't get through to the cable company
you do something
like one based on truth based on
anything andy's just acting out scenes
from his favorite movies
so swayze runs boom tackles the guy off
the motorcycle dude's like your dad bro
comes at him swayze ducks scissor kick
slime the guy has sweetie's head and he
says i used to
guys like you in prison by the looks of
this guy this is not consensual sex
we're talking about
we see bad guy had a gun the whole time
he's like i'm gonna kill you the
old-fashioned way swizzy's like not this
time
that subtext he doesn't say that
bypasses the gun hooks the
arm back to the secret move he used
before to kill somebody he feels so bad
about it but this time he has to do it
because self-defense
takes the esophagus out of the neck area
you can't eat
you'll starve to death and that is
roadhouse
what should i do next i'm calling to
lodge a complaint
about the seaweed and almond under eye
cream i purchased from you guys
oh my problem is it smells terrible yeah
i even mixed it with another under eye
cream and it still smelled so i ruined
two eye creams
yes i will hold
forever young i wanna be
forever young do you really wanna live
forever
all right we need to do some basic
organization
where do you put your bills when they
come i read the magazines
and give the rest to andy which i
organized into a pile
or stack that i put into the freezer
why so they won't get lost
bingo
okay you have to pay these good thing i
didn't lose them
so ben why causoni glad you asked chris
you know there's fast food hamburgers
there's fast food mexican there's fast
food chinese blah blah blah have you
ever wondered why there isn't a fast
food option for italian food
what about pizza pizza never heard of it
that's what people will be saying in 20
years because pizza is
old news chris pizza is your
grandfather's calzone i never thought of
it that way what i'm talking about is a
portable
delicious meal that is its own container
it's a whole new spin on italian fast
casual dining
amazing now you of all people like this
i'm gonna use low-fat ingredients game
changer and i will call my new
italian fast casual eatery the locale
calzone zone
that idea is literally the greatest idea
i have ever heard in my life
that idea is terrible hey dude
wake up man oh morning tom twilight
is dope i told you i couldn't put it
down
it was like she was peering into my soul
sing it friend here
book two twilight new moon
get cracking there's a second book and a
third
and a fourth no way
am i team edward yes do i share his
concerns about turning bella
though absolutely not yeah edward's
primary goal at
all times is bella's protection can you
please
please be quiet sorry sorry let's
keep it down be considerate this way tom
bella's love for edward
is being tested by jacob
not exactly the vulture okay you know
what all right i'm gonna go do my work
in the conference room cause you guys
are the worst
you seem tense leslie you know what you
should do read twilight
read twilight yeah thanks
sometimes i think she's in the vulture
[Laughter]
can i interest anyone in an authentic a
japanese abraca foster
scrambled eggs eaten with chopsticks
okay
you know maybe we should negotiate while
we're eating oh what's the rush plenty
of time for that later
you know what might put you in the mood
to talk is a couple of brewskis
and a calendar featuring some of your
favorite female wrestlers
oh yeah nope you know the way to a man's
heart yeah okay let's talk
you got it you said it was just odds and
ends it is yeah and some furniture and
the plasma tv
you haven't even folded up the boxes yet
dude deep blue sea
greatest movie ever made that's the
canadian version
22 extra minutes and there's a bonus
audio track where ll cool j wraps all
his dialogue
what we're watching this right now
pop it in no we should really pack this
room up and get moving
so this is a really big room i need
packed up guys
this is your bedroom no
it's a spare room i converted into a
walk-in closet
slash home fitness center what is that
oh i strapped an mp3 player to one of
those floor cleaning robots
call him dj roomba little guy cruises
around and plays music what's hot dj
roomba
dj
for a little while mark why am i gonna
love it
skye mall come check out my tent
i ordered a bunch of crap off skymall i
got my tv
my xbox dvd awesome bed right there
dj roomba's in the mix uh it's like i'm
not even camping
this is actually a dog couch but it's
super comfortable
i'm sorry but the ben wyatt that i know
i just don't think he'd be happy sitting
here
faffing around i'm not fapping around
i've sunk myself into my hobbies
here i'll show you my claymation project
okay now i've been working pretty hard
on this and
i think it's really good so just hang on
to your hat okay
okay here it goes
oh great
did you pause it no i hang on
oh my god that's the whole thing
that's three weeks of work you're gonna
be okay no no no no i'm not
you see in my head i thought that was
really really cool
i i i emailed leslie two days ago and i
compared it to avatar
you